so you just carbonate anything you just
flatch anything up onto there it smells
like Flintstone vitamins mmm
that sounds pretty good yeah it's
actually not bad no oh really sweet
really sweet like candy they made this
as a soda I feel like this would do
raisi well like a 5-hour energy but it's
like it's got some ghosts - dude 5-hour
energy got popped up yeah though it
looks like very diluted I don't know
about this one
yeah well it's actually not that bad you
don't like it I like that one well that
is vomit right you like it tasted like
vinegar and baking soda
coconut water makes an awful soda no
it's like coke car smells kind of weird
though smells like coffee
oh it's really bad Oh
I don't think this is that bad at all I
think this is pretty good actually no
it's like it took watered-down coffee
and you put salt in it and then just let
it sit there are you gonna drink the
rest from here no you wanted yes more
please oh I love milk so I think this is
gonna be good
I'm from Wisconsin so milk something I
take great pride in oh it's so bad it's
almost like what I imagined a whip it
tastes like I like it
no a little late I would shoot the man
who invented this to prevent everybody
else from having it it's really bad
don't make this at home please oh god
you did not make pickle soda I'm gonna
throw up you gave us carbonated pickle
juice I don't want to do it I don't want
to do it oh god I don't want to do it oh
god oh oh god no no no no no I can see
it being like a delicacy and like a mr.
block country this is what we drink on
Easter like it's tradition like
carbonated pickle juice